Ось такі емоції викликає німецький автобан.
Але для більшості німців швидкісна їзда є цілком буденним явищем.
Німеччина могла би скоротити викиди мільйонів тонн CO2 на рік –
якби запровадила обмеження швидкості на автобанах.
То чому ж загалом екологічно свідомі німці досі не відпускають педаль газу?
Дебати про обмеження швидкості вже давно розколюють Німеччину.
Значна кількість населення "за", але голоси "проти" теж доволі гучні.
Безглуздо їхати зі швидкістю 200 лише для власного задоволення.
Гадаю, це треба зберегти. Бо ми і так скрізь себе обмежуємо.
Бензин, вочевидь, все ще недостатньо дорогий, щоб люди їздили повільніше.
Для чого ми створюємо машини потужністю понад 50 кінських сил, якщо їздити можна лише 100 км/год?
Такі дискусії часто не підкріплені жодними фактами.
Ця дискусія дуже емоційна.
Знайомтеся, це Катя Діль. Вона авторка книжки про мобільність у Німеччині.
Люди хочуть почуватися вільними мати право їздити дуже швидко.
Німеччина має понад 13 000 кілометрів автобанів.
З якісними і безкоштовними для автомобілістів дорогами.
У більшості інших провідних країн діє обмеження швидкості.
Натомість у Німеччині на 70 відсотках автобанів можна їхати як завгодно швидко.
Противники обмеження швидкості аргументують, що в Німеччині
менше смертей на дорогах, ніж в інших країнах, наприклад у Франції чи Італії.
Але експерти Німецької ради з безпеки дорожнього руху стверджують,
що автобан був би ще безпечнішим, якби обмеження таки запровадили.
Крім безпеки, дедалі частіше обговорюється й інший аспект: клімат.
Усі дослідження сходяться в одному: обмеження швидкості зменшить викиди СО2.
Питання лише в тому, наскільки?
Згідно з останнім дослідженням Федерального відомства із захисту довкілля,
Німеччина могла би заощаджувати до 6,7 мільйона тонн CO2 на рік,
якби швидкість на автобанах обмежили до 120 км/год.
Це приблизно стільки ж, скільки такі країни, як Руанда чи Еритрея, спричиняють за рік.
Інше, більш оптимістичне дослідження оцінює зменшення викидів лише в 1,1 мільйона тонн на рік.
Але що такий потенціал зменшення викидів - від 1 до 6 мільйонів тонн CO2 на рік - насправді означає для Німеччини?
Противники обмеження швидкості стверджують, що зменшення викидів буде незначним.
Джуліо Маттіолі досліджує транспортну та кліматичну політику в Технічному університеті Дортмунда.
Вони просто обирають той знаменник, за яким зменшення викидів просто смішні.
Але якщо обрати правильний знаменник, то зменшення викидів буде значним.
Під знаменником експерт має на увазі прогалину між тими викидами,
які німецький трафік повинен виділяти згідно із законом, і тими, що насправді виділяються.
У 2022 році викиди CO2, спричинені транспортом, перевищили передбачену норму на 9 мільйонів тонн.
За даними Федерального відомства із захисту довкілля, обмеження швидкості суттєво зменшило б цей показник.
Ліміт швидкості - це елементарний захід, який несе із собою безліч переваг:
з точки зору безпеки, меншої кількості смертей на дорогах. І він діє майже в кожній іншій країні світу.
Але чимало німців таких аргументів не поділяють.
Для них швидка їзда - це прояв свободи, а автомобіль - частина їхньої культури.
Для деяких німців автомобіль є частиною ДНК.
На жаль, я думаю, це почалося ще з Адольфа Гітлера.
У 1930-х роках Гітлер пообіцяв модернізувати Німеччину,
створити робочі місця та стимулювати технологічний розвиток.
Це стало фундаментом для створення однієї з найдавніших мереж автомагістралей у світі.
Спершу без будь-яких обмежень швидкості.
Але коли, під час Другої світової війни ресурси стали дефіцитними,
для економії палива дозволялося розвивати швидкість лише до 80 кілометрів на годину.
Після війни мобільність, незалежність у пересуванні, стала надважливою для багатьох німців.
Німеччина була зруйнована, зневірена.
Люди поверталися з фронту і автомобіль для багатьох був своєрідним символом свободи.
З розвитком німецького автопрому бути власником авто могли дозволити собі дедалі більше людей.
Автомобілебудування відбувалося паралельно з відбудовою економіки.
А швидка їзда дорівнювала свободі.
У Західній Німеччині нацистський закон про обмеження швидкості був скасований у 1952 році.
Після возз'єднання країни в 1990 році всі обмеження швидкості на автобані зникли.
Протягом десятиліть багато німців відстоювали це право.
Кожен, хто піднімав питання обмеження швидкості, зустрічав шалений опір.
Імовірно, це пов'язано з тим, що у країні із мільйонами автомобілів
та якісними дорогами швидкість сприймають як свободу, доступну кожному.
Це фактично національна гордість.
Туристи навіть спеціально приїжджають до Німеччини, аби погасати автобанами.
За кілька сотень євро можна орендувати автомобіль преміум-класу
і "насолоджуватися легендарними німецькими автобанами",
"тиснути педаль газу на повну" із "максимальною швидкістю 300 км/год!"
Але якщо всім так подобається швидка їзда, то чому ж Німеччина -
одна з небагатьох країн, де це ще не заборонено?
Навряд чи це можна вважати пережитком нацистської епохи.
А от процвітаюча автомобільна промисловість, яка дала багатьом німцям відчуття свободи у післявоєнний час,
звичайно, все ще існує.
І є дуже впливовою.
У Німеччині існує так званий "ефект обертових дверей".
Коли політик залишає державну службу та переходить до промислових чи лобістських організацій.
Ці тісні зв’язки стали очевидними, коли ексміністр транспорту Німеччини
зустрічався з представниками промисловості 80 разів
протягом свого майже чотирирічного перебування на посаді.
З екологічними організаціями він зустрічався лише один раз.
Новий уряд продовжує надавати автомобільному лобі привілеї.
На останньому саміті з мобільності були присутні фактично лише представники автомобільних компаній.
Тож не дивно, що уряд часто вступається за інтереси автомобільної промисловості.
Наприклад, коли йдеться про обмеження викидів або розширення автомагістралей.
Невідомо, чи чинило автомобільне лобі в уряді активний спротив обмеженню швидкості.
Але німецькі консерватори та ліберали виступають проти обмеження.
Як і, власне, сам автопром.
Нам не потрібне загальне обмеження швидкості на відкритих дорогах.
Сімон Шютц є представником Німецької асоціації автомобільної промисловості.
Будь-які обмеження мають бути відповідними до ситуації.
На думку представників асоціації, цифрові дорожні знаки з лімітом швидкості доречні,
наприклад, при поганій погоді. Але загальне обмеження швидкості
майже ніяк не впливає на клімат чи безпеку на дорогах.
Асоціація посилається на дослідження, згідно з яким
обмеження швидкості може обійтися Німеччині у понад мільярд євро.
Підрахували, скільки часу втратять німці, якщо їздитимуть повільніше
і скільки зарплати вони можуть недорахуватися через це.
Натомість у іншому дослідженні йдеться про те, що Німеччина могла б навпаки,
заощаджувати сотні мільйонів щороку, обмеживши швидкість.
Мовляв, переваги фінансово переважують недоліки:
менше споживання палива, менше автомобільних аварій, менше викидів СО2.
Нещодавні спроби запровадити обмеження швидкості зазнали поразки в парламенті.
Тому що представники однієї з правлячих партій - вільні демократи заблокували таке рішення.
Натомість деякі противники швидкісного ліміту вказують на альтернативні способи скорочення викидів: електромобілі.
Багато автовиробників нині переорієнтовуються на електрокари.
Адже ЄС заборонив продаж нових бензинових і дизельних автомобілів з 2035 року.
Але попри деякі заохочення з боку держави далеко не кожен німець
може фінансово дозволити собі купівлю електромобіля.
До того ж, Німеччина має покращити місцевий громадський транспорт
у сільській місцевості та розширити залізничну інфраструктуру.
Але ці рішення потребують часу.
Багато дослідників довкілля підкреслюють, що обмеження швидкості -
це найшвидший спосіб скоротити викиди в короткостроковій перспективі.
Якщо німецький уряд не може змусити себе встановити швидкісний ліміт,
то яким чином вони збираються зменшити викиди від авто?
Гадаю, нам потрібні нові, кращі символи статусу чи кращі мрії, ніж швидка їзда чи володіння автомобілем.
Для декого обмеження швидкості - це посягання на особисту свободу.
Але це засвідчило б місце Німеччини поруч із іншими передовими країнами світу.